اليقطاموا على المكارم والمهالك عند
الضروره وثبات الجيش عند المخاوف هذا هو
وصف الشجاعه والايرانيون شجعان والوصف
للرئيس الامريكي بايضا وايضا نظيره
الفرنسي مكرون هؤلاء هم الغرب هو رئيس
ايران دعوته الى ما يصفه باحباط مخططات
الاعداء هذه المخططات يبدو انها تاتي من
النظام بنفسه افعلوا اي شيئا لجعل
المواطنين يعتقدون ان الاحتجاجات من عمل
الاجانب حديث المرشد بحسب تسريبات نشرتها
ايران انترناشوناللها بعد قليل
شجاعه الايرانيين تتوازن مع ارتفاع عدد
القتلى قتله الاحتجاجات
462 ابي حسب منظمه حرانه الحقوقيه الضغط
يتزايد وفي المقابل تجديد وسائل القمع عما
يتضروره الاعتقالات بالطبع جزء منها حتى
في صفوف النظام محمد باقر باختيار القائد
السابق بالحرس الثوري اعتقله الامن وهو من
فجر قصه مساء انني اصلا باختيار المطلع
على التفاصيل بحكم منصبه السابق ووصف
النظام بانه هويه وغير مسؤول الاختطاف
وقتل المسؤولين الحكوميين والنشطاء
والصفيين في جميع انحاء العالم وسيله اخرى
15 مسؤولا في واشنطن واوروبا والشرق
الاوسط كشف الامر لواشنطن بوست هذا الى
جانب اداه اخرى معتمده تشويه السمعه
المتشدده هاجم امير حسين موسى
خاتمي وايضا روحاني واتهمتهم بحراسه
المصالح الامريكيه في ايران
مولوي عبد الحميد ايضا امام السنه في
بلوشستان الذي طالب السلطات بوقف القمه لم
يسلم بالطبع
[موسيقى]
لم ينجح تشويه هو السمعه والدليل ما
شاهدناه قبل قليل تجمعات للتضامن مع مولوي
عبد الحميد الشباب وقود الانتفاضه لم يعد
يصدق روايات النظام وباتوا يشهدون الخناقه
اكثر فاكثر دعواتنا لاضراب العام من
الخامس وحتى السابع من ديسمبر الجاري وفي
مقابل ذلك النظام لا يصمت هذا قديم يجددها
القتل والصاق التهما بالانتحار المتزايد
اصلا في ايران بسبب الوضع المتنبي هذا
مراهقه عرش يا امام ساده 16 عاما انتحر
بعد يومين فقط من اطلاق صراحه اعتقل لمده
خرتي ايام بتهمه اسقاط العمامه
لكن حال انتحر امنتحر والدته ذهبت الى
الاحتمال الثاني ماذا فعل بك عدو عدو
الشرف هؤلاء انت لم تكن اللي تنتحر هذه
الاحاديث جعلت التهديدات تظهر وقوات الامن
اقتحمت منزل الاسره وحددت افرادها اذا
تكلمتم سينالكم السوء الناشطه الاهوازيه
عاطفه انعامي ايضا مثال اخر عثر عليها
مقتوله في شقتها وشقيقها ومنها فدى ان انت
حاره شقيقته سيناريولا فقط لا يمنع ذلك
ايضا السلطات من القتل المباشر في عباد
اكبر مثال شرشا نيك نام 30 وعدت زوجته
الثار لن اكون امراه ان لم تنتقل لك
اشكرك